So what's a colloid engine.
So the same rocket people that,
um, came up with, with these ideas for electric propulsion,
um, probably in the middle of last century, uh,
also realize that there's one more place to get charged particles
from. Um, if you're going to be using electric propulsion,
so you can take a gas and you can ionize it,
but there are also some liquids, particularly ionic liquids,
which is what we use that you also can use as a source of ions.
And if you have ions and you put them in a field, you generate a force.
So they recognize that. But, um,
part of being able to leverage that technique is being able to kind of
manipulate those liquids on a scale of nanometers or, or, you know,
very few microns. So, you know,
the diameter of a human hair or something like that. And in the fifties,
there was no way to do that.
So they wrote about it in some books and then it kind of died for a little bit.
And then with, um, Silicon memes,
computer processors, and,
and when Foundry started becoming more ubiquitous and my advisor,
um, started at MIT, uh,
kind of put those ideas back together and was like, Hey, actually,
there's now a way to build this and bring this other technique to life.
Um, and so the way that,
the way that you actually get the ions out of those liquids, um,
is you put the liquid in, uh, in again,
a strong electric field and the electric field stresses the liquid
and you keep increasing the field and eventually the liquid will assume, uh,
I'll go this way, uh, conical shape. Um, it's the,
it's when the electric field pressure that's pulling on it, exactly balances,
the liquid's own restoring force, which is its surface tension.
So you have this balance and the liquid assumes a cone, um,
when it's perfectly balanced like that. And at the tip of a cone, um,
the radius of curvature goes to zero right at the tip. Um, and,
uh, the radius, sorry, the electric field, um,
right at the tip of a sharp object would go to infinity. Uh,
cause it goes, um, uh,
is one over the radius and one over the radius squared.
And instead of the electric field going to infinity and maybe
like generating a wormhole or something, um,
a jet of ions instead starts issuing from the tip of that
liquid.
So the field becomes strong enough there that you can pull ions out of the
liquid, right?
It was the liquid we're talking about. There's a bunch of different ones.
I can do it with, um, with different types of liquids. It depends on, you know,
how easily you can free ions from their neighbors.
And if it has enough surface tension so that you can build up a high enough
electric field. But, um, what we use are called ionic liquids,
and they're really just positive. They're, uh, they're very similar to salts,
but they happen to be liquid over a really wide range of temperatures.
This sounds like really cool. Okay. So how big is the, uh,
how big is the corner we talking? Uh, what, what's the size of this corner?
Well, if you have a cone that's emitting pure ions. Um, the,
I can't remember if it's the radius or diameter, but, um,
that emission is happening from that. Kona is something like 20 nanometers.
Oh, as a magic, something slightly bigger. But so like this is,
so this is tiny, tiny,
hence the only being able to do it recently. Yeah. That's right.
So this is all controlled by computer, I guess like, or like how,
how do you control something?
How do you create a cone that generates ions at a scale of nanometers? Exactly.
So.
The kind of main trick to making this work is that physically
we manufacture hundreds or thousands of sharp structures and then
supply the liquid to the tips. So that does a few things.
It makes sure that we know where the ion beams are forming,
so we can put holes in the grid above them to let them actually leave instead of
hitting. Right. Cool. Um,
but it also reduces the actual field. We have to, the voltage,
we have to apply to create that field because the field will be much stronger if
we can already give the liquid a tip to form on. Um,
and those tips, we form have radio. We have curvature, um,
on the order of probably like single microns.
So we are working at a little bit larger scale,
but once we create that support and the electric field can be focused at that
tip, then the tiny little cone can form.
So there's something there's an already like a hard material that like
gives you the base for the cone and the pouring liquid over it.
From the bottom. Yeah. It's poorest.
So we actually supply it from the back of the chip and then.
Forms on top on that structure. Yeah.
And then you somehow make it like super sharp, the liquid.
So the ions can live.
Then we have applied that field to get those ions in that same field,
then accelerates them.
That's awesome. And there's like a bunch of these.
Yeah. I should have, I should have brought something. Um, so.
You can just pretend that you have some nanometre cones on. Yeah.
So actually, you know, kind of about this scale, um, we build,
we call them thruster chips and it's just a convenient form factor and it's a
square centimeter. And on each square centimeter today,
we have about 500 of the actual physical,
we call them emitters those physical cones. Um,
and we're working on increasing that by a factor of four in the coming
months in size or in number and the density,
the number of emitters within the same square centimeter.
So that thing,
cause I think I've seen pictures of you with like a tiny thing in your hand.
That must be the thing. Okay. So that's an engine. Yeah.
Um, so that is kind of the ionization chamber and
thrust producing part of it. What's not shown in that picture,
um, is the propellant tank,
so we can keep supplying more and more of the liquid to those, um,
emission sites.
And then we also provide a power electronic system that talks to the
spacecraft and turns our device on and off.
The core engine. That's the core of the code.
Um, it's the way I've been talking about it. It's um,
more of ion electrospray colloid, um,
tends to mean like liquid droplets coming off of the jet,
but if you make smaller and smaller cones, you get pure ions.
So we're kind of like a subset of Cola.
Yes. What, uh, aspects of this,
you said that it's been full of mystery from the physics perspective,
what aspects of this are understood and what are still
full of mystery?
Yeah. Recently, um,
we've been understanding the kind of instabilities and
stable regimes of, um, you know,
how much liquid do you supply and, and what field do you apply and um,
why is it flickering on and off or why does it have these weird behaviors?
So that's in the past just couple of years,
that's become much more understood. Um,
I think the two areas that come to mind as far as, um,
not as well understood are, um, the boundary between,
you know, you have, um, we,
we actually use kind of big molecular ions.
And if you're looking at the molecular scale,
you have, you know,
some ions that you've extracted and they're in this electric field,
one eye on, you know, it's a big molecule,
it's getting energy from the electric field.
And some of that energy is going into the bonds and making it vibrate and doing
weird things to it.
Sometimes it breaks them apart and then zooming out to the
whole beam.
The beam has some behaviors as this beam of ions.
And there's a big gap between what are those? What, how do you connect those?
Um, and how do we understand that better so that we can understand the beam
performance of, of the engine?
Is that a theory question or is that an engineering question?
Theory?
Definitely where Axion is a startup and we're more in the business
of building and testing and observing, um, and characterizing.
Um, and we're not really diving much into that theory right now.